bienvenue dans PAF pa vous le savez
c'est cette émission on prend un peu de
distance avec l'actualité on essaie de
la mettre en perspective on en débat
avec Jean-Charles lajoiniie bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes éditeur voilà Florence
Mercadé qui est avocate ça va bien ça va
très bien merci Jean-Luc badek qu'on ne
présente plus ben non BJ pas
tous mapha lvoui ça va bien ça va très
bien qu' présente plus dans bleu ouais
vous avez vous avez fait vos vœux au
Football Club de trape absolument la
semaine dernière et vous y étiez
Patrice c'était devant les
téléspectateurs il y était fabà'éta
magnifique c'était super bien merci
Patrice vonique ça va bien oui bonjour
Patrice ça va versill plus se porte bien
très bien au top très bien et Antonin
Moulard alors vous êtes blogueur vous
êtes aussi le le cofondateur d'un très
bon journal gratuit prix libre prix
libre on peut payer si on
veut donc à mon avis je suis pas sûr a
beaucoup de G
quiououi on récolle beaucoup d'argent
grâce au prix bien plus bien plus que si
on faisait un prix fixe à 1 € par
exemple et ben ça s'appelle en tout cas
le complément on va y penser nous ouais
donc on va le payer n pardon on l'avait
pris gratuit
c'était pour la démo pourrait payer les
prochains alors on a beaucoup de sujets
à aborder cette semaine enfin il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses sur le plan
international sur le plan national on va
peut-être commencer par l'Europe avec
bah la victoire de cypras d'Antony
cypras en Grèce et de du parti CIN de ce
qu'on appelle la gauche
radicale avec des conséquences peut-être
pour l'Europe avec des conséquences
peut-être aussi pour la France on va on
va en discuter dans un instant d'abord
cette cette victoire cette victoire de
la gauche radicale en en Grèce elle
était attendue est-ce que vous la
comprenez et et qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Jean-Charles mais moi j'étais
épaté parce que j'ai écouté les
informations j'avais l'impression que
c'est Mélenchon qui avait été élu en
Grèce c'était absolument extraordinaire
il a fait campagne il était tout content
et après c'est sûrement bien enfin parce
que il y avait il y avait sûrement un
besoin pour les Grecs de changer un
petit peu de d'environnement politique
est-ce que c'est bien pour l'Europe
est-ce que fondamentalement ce sera épat
pour les Grecs on peut quand même
légitimement douter c'est ça va
peut-être donner des idées à d'autres en
tout cas ça va donner des idées à
d'autres mais surtout je dire il a enfin
il y a quelques précédents un peu d'un
are pays mais il a promis quand même la
lune à tout le monde et on sait très
bien qu'il pourra pas tenir là j'entendg
oui j'entendais une une électrice
grecque qui disait mais s'il ne faisait
qu'un 5è de ce qu'il a promis ce serait
déjà pas mal mais on peut craindre qu'il
en fasse à peine le 10e alors est-ce que
les gens sonont pas hyper déçus il y a
il y a une autre façon de poser la
question parce que au au fond euh par
exemple Angela Merkel voilà pendant des
années a refusé de de négocier sur sur
laadte grec est-ce qu'elle aurait pas
mieux fait de de d'aider son
prédécesseur qui s'appelait Samaras qui
était plus proche d'elle que plutôt que
de jouer comme ça en refusant à chaque
fois et de faire en sorte que les Grecs
votent pour ceux qui n'avaient jamais
gouverné mais juste un mot elle les a
quand même aidé et l'Europe a quand même
aidé les Grecs de façon incroyable on
leur a prêté des sommes faramineuses et
le problème grec n'est pas qu'un
problèmeou s'est sauvé aussi he on s on
s'est sauvé aussi enfin c'est quand même
aussi un pays où personne ne paye un
sous d'impôt où on peut tout acheter au
noir les réformes avent commencé à être
fa les réformes avaient commencé mais
enfin je veux dire tout n'est pas de la
faute de l'Europe c'est quand même un
pays qui vivait complètement en marge de
la c'est la faute de l'Europe je dis que
l'Europe aurait peut-être pu anticiper
enfin certains pays auraient peut-être
pu anticiper ça euh oui oui non moi je
trouve je trouve que l'événement il est
pasement il est pas ton que notre ami
cyprin s'est fait 36 % des voix am
dès que quelqu'un est au pouvoir est
amoui se le met dans la poche direct
l'événement c'est qu'il a très très
grande majorité qui pas voté pour lui
parce qu'après tout il promettait de pas
payer de dettes il promettait d'effacer
la dette il promettait tout ce vient de
citer et finalement on se rend compte
que c'est simplement un tiers de la
population qu'on qui un tiers qui a voté
pour lui pour moi l'événement il est
surtout là et on va probablement
reparler dans d'autres émissions ou plus
tard comme d'autres promett la lune en
France qui qui qui ne font que
finalement que que 30 % des voix ce qui
est beaucoup quand on prend en absolu 30
% mais en réalité il y en a 70 qui sont
même pas d'accord pour dire je vote pour
lui parce qu'il va raser gratis bon pour
moi le vrai événement il est là pour le
reste Patrice c'est vrai que je crois
que l'Europe a déjà fait beaucoup mais
elle a fait l'Europe elle a fait
essentiellement pour elle-même et c'est
vrai que quand on donne autant d'argent
à une nation celle des Grecs mais ça a
été le cas également l'Espagne du
Portugal de la France France c'est vrai
qu'on en attend un
retourargent on a exigé qu'elle
rembourse sa dette il y a des choses
absolument FAM il a par exemple des gens
du FMI quelqu'un du FMI qui était qui
était vous savez la troï qui s'occupait
justement qui a dit il faut que la la la
la Grèce rembourse absolument sa dette
et maintenant ce type est parti du FMI
il est dans une banque et il dit
finalement c'était intenable on aurait
jamais dû leur demander ça c'estàdire
que les gens qui qui avaient une
position très dure quand ils étaient aux
affaires avec la grec change
complètement d'avis une fois qu' sont
par quand même rendettement de toutes
les familles quand un moment donné vous
avez une dette dans une famille la
banque fait le max pour la récupérer et
un moment donné c'est vous dire bon ben
non c'est très bien pass ouais donc on
passe au
sur est-ce que vous avez tenu compte que
la Grèce est quand même le pays où la
démocratie a été
inventée bon et à partir de là vous avez
un peuple qui a voté alors c'est 30 %
bah oui si on fait la comparaison avec
les nôtres c'est plutôt al sy absolument
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut noter surtout
c'est que un peuple a voté pour
l'émergence d'un nouveau personnel
politique d'ailleurs comme en Italie et
il faut se réjouir que de nouveaux
hommes et femmes politiques interviennne
maintenant sur la scène européenne donc
je plutôt bien alors je suis pas je suis
pas un gauchiste moi he mais il faut
quand même se il faut VO je peux
terminer mon cher Mustafa non non mais
on peut pas il faut terminer il faut
laisser terminer une pH é élu et c'est
ça qui la est que la démocratie a joué
son rôle oui euh l'émergence d'une
nouvelle équipe est aujourd'hui arrivée
en Grèce elle est arrivée aussi en
Italie il faut espérer que ça arrivera
aussi chez nous pourquoi pas et en tous
les cas il ne s'agit pas là de voir
gauche droite c'est vrai que j'ai trouvé
l'attitude de Mélanchon absolument
incroyable mais en même temps on on va
parler un petit peu après parce Marine
Le Pen aussi a revendiqué la victoire en
fait qui revendique la victoire les
partis sont en dehors en dehors des
parties traditionnell et là où c'est
important je crois de noter c'est que
une
population qui souffre a dit stop il
faut j'adore ce terme renverser la table
il se trouve que là la personnalité du
bonhomme est plutôt orienté vers
l'extrême gauche mais si tu étais
quelqu'un d'extrême droite je crois
que il a der fait un accord avec un par
d'extrême droite
P pardon Florence mercad oui la seule
chose qui quand même extrêmement
étonnant c'est que 24 heur après il
s'allie avec un parti nationaliste
homophobe antieuropéen qui est
extrêmement dangereux donc depuis on
entend plus mélanch d'ailleurs parce que
il était là
diman
euré homopob voilà ce qui est quand même
très très contrariant et très très
inquiétant mais c'est un signe lancé à
l'Europe pour dire on va faire le bras
de fer je pense ça fait partie des comme
dans toute négociation on part avec des
demandes extrêmement virulentes pour
après il va dégrader ses demandes je
pense comme dans
tout il mettrait une cravate quand
Merkel retirerit sa
culotte ça devient
intéressant je pense qu'il faut replacer
les choses dans leur contexte c'estàd
que le peuple grec depuis depuis la
crise n'a pas arrêté de régresser en
terme de de réforme de de sécurité
sociale de de tout de fction ont été
virés enfinou il y avait beaucoup aussi
ENF crise de l'État quand même il y
avait il y avait surtout une une crise
de la dette une crise de la dette c'est
des taux d'intérêt
faramineux qui sont on le savait déjà
très bien que qui pourront jamais être
remboursés pourtant on a continué à
mettre des taux d'intérêt de plus en
plus élevés non les banques ont mis des
taux d'intérêt mais la banque
européenneour rembours la différence
plus compliqué que ça c'est plus
compliqué que
ça la question la question aussi c'est
euh les les banques il faut peut-être
mettre en place des réformes pour qu'on
puisse contrôler les banques et arrêter
de de mettre des taux d'intérêt qui sont
inrembboursables qui au final pent un
pays met à plat un pays
complètement c'est surtout la est met à
PL oui mais la dette elle elle est qui
demande les taux d'intérêt c'est les
banques en il pe bien aussi de payer ses
impôts quand on habitant je pense que
l'autre voilà c'est l'ut il y av aussi
une réforme de l'État son autre
challenge c'est en interne c'est aussi
de nettoyer en interne d'enlever toutes
les les problématiques de copinage et
d'essayer de remettre les gens un peu
sur la sur sur la voie et la voie droite
c'estd de payer ses impôts et de
remettre et ça c'est un de ces
challenges il le sait ça vaituer le
débat à mon avis ce serait de poser la
question de savoir pourquoi a-t-on fait
une Europe avec autant de pays est-ce
qu'ils étaient tous avec des critères
pour rentrer dans l'Europe et au
quelqu'un peut-être qu'on a besoin de
plus d'Europe mais peut-être d'une
Europe aut il unong au départ sur
l'état
mond tout le monde a menti dès le départ
les chiffres étaient tronqués le peuple
grec qui n conna
pas a été trompé et là qu'est-ce qu' a
dit le peuple grec stop la classe
politique traditionnelle dehors on en
met des
nouveau c'est pas c'est pas seulement un
problème d'homme ou de femme c'est un
problème de politique et de ligne
idéologique ah bah non non non non on
peut très bien remettre un homme il
répond au rapport de force moi je je
pense pas que répondra au voilà donc la
question aujourd'hui qui se pose pour le
peuple grec c'est la construction d'un
rapport de force vis-à-vis de cette
ligne politique économique qui fout le
pays en l'air quoi mais complètement et
donc moi je pense qu'il faut il faut que
le peuple grec soit uni et alors je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous
l'alliance
avec pour pour changer ligc a aussi
besoin de l'Europe
dis y a de stratégies dans ce cas
il la Grèce dit merde à l'Europe et
voilà c'est pas dans c'est pas dans sa
politique de dire merde
à pas quitter mais mais il faut que de
toute façon pour pouvoir négocier de
toute façon avec les autres pays il faut
que le peuple grec soit uni et ça va
aussi dépendre de ce qui va se passer en
Europe et dans les autres
pays c'est aussi un signal pour les
autres peuples européens ce vote pour
que les peuples européens se prennent en
charge et mettent en place des vrais
systèmes de solidarité aujourd'hui tout
tout F camp je suis d'accord avec toi
mais il va falloir aussi faire attention
il va falloir qu'il fasse attention au
sein sommes pas grec la responsabilité
non mais juste au sein de son parti
politique il faut qu'il reste un parce
qu'il y a aussi plusieurs courants dans
son parti politique à lui donc faut pas
qu'il se met se fiche dessus attends
juste termine il faut pas non plus qu'il
se fiche dessus avec le partenaire de
lundi qui est un partenaire nationaliste
qui n'a pas les mêmes valeurs non plus
que lui
doncjà un peu plus extrémiste voilà
c'est ça mais il faut qu'ils arrivent à
rester tous unis y compris dans son
parti ce qui est pas gagné c'est surtout
faut toujours qu' faut que les choses
soient simples pour qu'elles soi
comprises de tous on est parti avec des
critères bah que tout le monde les
respecte ou alors on négocie les
critères mais les futurs critères à la
limite on veut renégocier une Europe
plus sociale une Europe autrement moi je
veux bien mais les futurs critères
faudra bien que tout le monde les
respecte donc si les futurs critères
c'est de pas rembourser une dette bah
les autres ne remboursont pas non plus
donné je veux bien qu'on dise il y a à
renégocier il y a à dire il y a à faire
moi ce que je considère c'est qu'àé il y
a des critères on doit les respecter où
on les renégocie mais tous ont les mêmes
critères c'est un mot de vérodique qui
n'a pas encore parlé oui ben moi je leur
souhaite bon courage parce que je vois
j'ai un exemple tout bête un médecin
dermatologue grec qui ne qui commençait
à être étouffé par les impôts parce
qu'il paye parce qu'il est solvable
vivait en Grèce il est parti travailler
ailleursou et ils font un peu tout ça
les gens qui sont sur le Val parce qu'
on VO bien la PE de la Bourse de la
Bourse grec donc c'est toi qui
connaissais le grec qui payit les impôts
voilà exactement non tout on peut pas
dire que tous les Grecs ne payaient pas
des impôts mais il y a un certain nombre
de gens dont les armateurs notamment
quelle position il va
avirénégal entre pves je reviens à
Mélenchon parce que c'est intéressant
mais c'est vrai que si on si on regarde
les ce qui s'est passé en Grèce il y
avait le pasoc qui était le le Parti
socialiste grec qui passe à 5 % et en
gros cpras dont on pourrait dire que
c'était le gauche qui passe à 30 % donc
on comprend que on comprend ce que ça le
fasse rêver est-ce que est-ce que la
situation est la même est-ce qu'il a la
capacité de tipras voilà on comprend que
ça fasse rêver Mélenchon mais Mélenchon
peu avant l'élection présidentielle il
était au fites des sondages il montait
semaine après semaine et il a il s'est
quand même tiré une balle dans le pied
tout seul il s'est massacré il ne
représente quasiment plus rien enfin je
veux dire lui c'est c'est exactement le
le l'exemple inverse le le le
contreexemple de de cypras quoi c'estàd
que Mélenchon plus il parle plus il veut
s'y faire plus il devient caricatural
moins il séduit il y a il y a pas de
programme il y a pas de chose alors il y
il y a quand même une alliance avec du
flot oui ah bah il est
sauvé non mais c'est
terrifiant c'est un problème c'est vrai
qu'en France la gauche radicale pour
l'instant n'est pas du tout uni il a
rapochement
r des rapochement qui font mais pour
l'instant il y a des appels alors ça
fera peut-être autour d'un appel à la
primaire pour les présidentielles parce
qu'il y a des appels à la primaire un
peu différents par exemple j'ai entendu
Julien Bayou porte-parole d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts aujourd'hui il me
semble qui appelé à une primaire du du
PS jusque jusqu'au front de gauche mais
pour pour une bonne raison c'est que
vous avez un sondage qui montre que
Marine Le Pen est à 29 ou 30 % en TER de
positionnement politique c'est vraiment
le Front National qui ressemble le plus
à ce qui s'est passé avec cypras en
Grèce c'estàdire que la position
actuelle je parle pas des idé je parle
pas du contenu desidées je parleement du
scénario politique le scénario politique
en France aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
Marine Le Pen qui est dans la même
positionéta pass avant les éle tu veux
dire pour RER la table pour rerser la
table c'est ça qui est assez terrible
d'ailleurs ve dire a avec avec demant
des résultats qui sont identiques ça
c'est à craindre mais par-dessus le
marché avec quand même dans les grands
thèmes idéologiques beaucoup de
ressemblance ce qui est très inquiétant
avec mar c'est que elle fait un un score
absolument épousoufflant dans ce sondage
alors que depuis 3 semaines elle est
inexistante tout le monde dit qu'elle s
planté soant très mauvaise elle a dit
très peu de choses elle a dit très peu
de choses le peu qu'elle a dit n'était
pas extrêm dit elle a raté la séquence
en ratant en ratant cette
séquence enfin tout le monde est unanime
pour reconnaître cet échec elle arrive à
30 entre 29 et 31 % donc c'est
extrêmement angoissant parce que le jour
elle va re bonne sur quelque chose alors
mais c'est terrible est-ce que ça un
rapport fait que le fait qu'elle soit
bonne ou mauvaise en fait c'est
peut-être ça la vraie question avec la
situation mais alors au même titre qu'on
ne sait pas si si est bon ou mauvais ce
que disait tout à l'heure mapha est
significatif effectivement il y a
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas voté de
cypras et il y a certainement beaucoup
de gens qui aujourd'hui pourra dire
avent la même trouille à l'égard de
ppras que nous à l'gard du Front
national c'est pour ça que le scénario
finalement est assz
et je reviens à ce que vous disiez
pardon tout à l'heure mais je vous donne
la parole après euh quand quand les
quand les vers disent il faudrait
peut-être une primaire avec la gauche et
les verrs c'est qu'il y a un vrai danger
c'est c'est c'est l'éumination de la
gauche dès le premier tour si jamais ils
son si jamais ils sentend pas si jamais
il y a pas qu'une seule candidature
cette élimination elle est courue
d'avance même oui c'est c'est sûr après
je pense qu'il faut vraiment construire
une dynamique et donc la base d'une
dynamique c'est c'est le rassemblement
quand même et sur des valeurs et un
socle commun je pense que si si toutes
les personnes qui sont en faveur de de
progrès social et écologique se mettent
en route ensemble ça peut ça peut donner
quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est ce qui s'était passé
ce qui s passé oui il faudra les
différence a que ce qui s'est passé il y
a 3 ans enfin 2 ans et demi bah il y a
une candidature europecologie les ver au
premier tour il y a une candidature PS
il y a une candidature Front de Gauche
enfin la gauche partie divisée quoi ouis
enfin elle est arrivée au deuxème tour
sans problème ah non non non elle est
pas arrivé au deè tour pas arrivé au deè
tour la gauche non comment Hollande bah
si Hollande c'est pas la gauche bah
nonéit moi c'est quasim une évidence
quoi je veux dire oui d'accord ENF c'est
quand même le représenté du Parti
socialiste et si si la gauche radicale
ne s'entend pas avec le Parti socialiste
c'est sûr qu'il y aura personne ni de de
ce que vous appelez la gauche pour le
Parti socialiste ou la gauche la gauche
radical au 2è tour en 2017 pas évident
tout est possible mais c'est bien vous
êtes optimiste relativement rêveur on
verra bien et il y a deux choses dans
ceage donc il y avait il y avait la
montée de de Marine Le Pen et il y a le
fait que Val est plutôt mieux placé
Hollande est-ce que ça veut dire quelque
chose ou pas
oui dans l'état actuel des
chque on voit bien les fluctuations de
l'opinion et ça va accélérer et ça va
avoir des mouvements encore plus forts
jusqu'à l'au de l'élection
présidentielle prochaine ça va beaucoup
bougé beaucoup changé regardez ce qui se
passe sur la loi Macron en ce moment je
vous avais dit tout à l'heure enfin
l'autre jour que il est probable que le
pauvre Macron serve de fusible à
l'ensemble c'est en train d'arriver
derrière est-ce que Manuel Val va garder
sa code de popularité il y a rien de
moins sûr et puis pour ce qui concerne
François Hollande on voit bien que il a
effectivement hérité de la montée des
sondages après les événements atroce du
mois de janvier on sait bien que ça ne
durera pas ça dure pas ça s'imprime pas
en tout cas politiqu ou mais Maron quand
même 60 % des Français sont pour ils
sont derrière 30 % dans 3 mois ou dans 6
mois bon voilà tout ça je l' d à 30 mois
des élections c'est vrai que François
Holland était à 3 % puis puisque c'est
une émission on prend du recul Patrice
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure on prend
un peu de recul prendre du recul et
commenter les sondages jour après jour
on voit immédiatement la montée la
descente des uns et des autres c'est un
peu compliqué c'est un exercice auquel
on trait mais mais il a des tendan je
veux dire la tendance marine de le pan
elle est quand même forte
là pour le coup on est plus sur les
sonondages on a parlé de sonâ de Marine
Le Pen mais c'est vrai qu'on est plutôt
sur une tendance de fond mais je je
répète c'est 30 % d'une population on ne
parle pas des 70 et moi je l'ai dit à
cette table je le redis chich à l'UMPS
et on l'a vu on l'a vu récemment
descendre dans la rue globalement cette
UMPS qui peut se retrouver sur des sur
des fondamentaux en France sur des
sujets d'importance où la France peut se
rassembler et faire des choses et
j'appelle à la coalition de ces deux
parties ch à
l's et là pour le coup et je termine moi
aussi ma phrase et moi aussi je termine
ma phrase par ce que je sais faire moi
aussi et donc pour le coup on serait non
pas dans un front républicain c'est pas
de ça dont je parle c'est pas un front
républicain contre le Front national
c'est de dire il y a une majorité en
France qui veulent des réformes de fond
et qui est pas justement la juste
position de politique droite gauche qui
s'affronte mais au contraire qu'on peut
se réunir sur des projets commun on a
parlé du terrorisme la dernière fois de
la sécurité on pourrait parler de
l'écologie
co si vous voulez parler si vous voulez
parler politique ENF comment ça se passe
c'est vrai que vous avez à droite
aujourd'hui un bon candidat pour la
droite qui Sarkozi et le bon candidat
pour le de pour le premier tour le bon
candidat pour le deè tour ça va Jup der
ce que vous dites c'est le seul qui est
capable de rassembler la droite la
gauche j'ai dis ça moi non mais je vous
le
dis c'est la conséquence de ce que vous
dites
deux sondages cond nature he qui vont
aré là ce sont les cantonnales et
ensuite les régionales vous pensez que
c'est condnat ah bien sûr évidemment ah
oui ou oui là vous en espérant que les
Français acceptent d'aller voter va être
amusant c'est l'élection de de de ce
dimanche là l'élection législative de de
voir les les SCOR que vont faire les
socialistes que vont faire les amis de
notre ami les les ver je sais même pas
s'ils se présentent il sont à 2 % 2 et
demi je sais pas on va voir mais enfin
ça va être
au législative législative
donc ça verra la semaine prochaine et on
verra intéressant très intéressant et on
va voir là aussi a y a une possibilité
que le Front national remporte ce siège
qui était qui ét tenu par les par les
socialistes c'est la démocratie on va
parler d'un sujet qui vous intéresse
Jean-Luc au premier plan je crois c'est
l'éducation bon alors après les
événements de janvier on s'est demandé
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire dans
l'éducation est-ce qu'il faut pour
revenir à l'éducation civique à la à la
morale je vous propose de de regarder un
sujet sur bah justement le retour à la
morale à l'école et et les discussions
que ça
entraîne laïcité citoyenneté valeur de
la République depuis les attentats de
Paris la ministre de l'Éducation les met
en avant et veut les réaffirmer à
l'école du primaire au lycée c'est ce
qu'elle a fait ce jeudi c'est nécessaire
et ça existe déjà dans le cadre des
programmes d'histoiregéographie au
collège au lycée aussi et dans le
casadre des programmes d'éducation
civique et de CGS au lycée aussi ce sont
des thèmes qui sont déjà abordés
notamment en 3e en classe de 3e en
éducation
civique l'enseignement de la laïcité
l'enseignement de la critique face aux
médias ce sont des choses qui sont
normalement abordées en classe déjà pour
aider les professeurs à aborder ces
thèmes 1000 enseignants et personnels
seront formés pendant 2 jours deuxè
annonce à partir de la rentrée 2015 un
nouvel enseignement moral et civique
sera mis en place mais aussi un
enseignement laïque du fait religieux un
enseignement laïque du fait religieux
oui c'est c'est quelque chose qui peut
sembler
important ceci dit je sais pas si dans
l'enseignement Laï du fait religieux on
ira jusqu'à l'athéisme ou ou le fait que
quelqu'un puisse être agnostique donc je
crois queil faut attendre de voir les
contenus et en plus comme toujours adapt
suivant le le public auquel on est
confronté les élèves consacreront 300
heures par an à l'Enseign moral et
civique ce qui représente une heure par
semaine une annonce jugée incomplète par
certains syndicats comment ça va être
organisé quelle formation comment vont
être organisé les les heures par rapport
aux heures déjà existantes est-ce qu'il
va y avoir une augmentation des heures
de présence à l'école c'est des annonces
mais avec quel moyen derrière la
ministre de l'Éducation a annoncé que
ces mesures coûteront 250 millions
d'euros sur 3 ans
Jean-Luc mec réaction sur voilà retour
de la morale je va pas prendre trop de
temps mais je voulais essayer
d'Ét nous avons tous une personnalité il
y a quatre critères qui déterminent nos
personnalités la génétique on est homme
ou femme de couleurs différentes grand
petit la génétique on y peut rien on
sait pas d'où ça vient on contrôle pas
les trois autres critères c'est
l'éducation l'environnement les
rencontres l'éducation a un rôle
primordial génétiquement on est comme on
est et c'est pas là pour un être humain
tout autant que pour une société mais
enfin on peut changer exactement donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
génétique qui ce que nous sommes
physiquement et mentalement à la
naissance
est transformé amélioré ou au contraire
empiré par l'éducation l'environnement
les rencontres l'éducation joue un rôle
primordial mais pas qu'à l'école aussi
dans la famille qu'on appelle
l'éducation VO alors l'éducation c'est
la capacité d'apprendre à un enfant un
jeune femme jeune fille garçon un
certain nombre de règles qu'on appelle
les valeurs c'est la transmission de ces
valeurs c'est l'éducation et ça se
transmet à l'école
autant alors pardon je termine juste
l'environnement a également un rôle très
très important on n'est pas le même si
on vit à traape ou si on vit à ne
l'environnement est différent et les
rencontres alors les rencontres c'est ça
peut être des rencontres qu'on provoque
ou des rencontres du hasard j'ai eu moi
l'immense chance dans mon existence de
rencontrer des gens qui m'ont donné des
bons guides et c'est ce qui fait que
j'ai une personnalité équilibrée alors
que je suis né plutôt avec d'autres
personnalités que ça donc voilà quatre
critères la génétique l'éducation
l'environnement les rencontres à partir
du moment où on arrive à maîtriser
convenablement l'éducation
l'environnement et les rencontres ça va
mieux oui alors justement l'éducation
c'est avant tout les parents moi j'ai
écouterérents témoignages bah c'est
surtout les parents parce que qui va
donner confiance à un enfant qui va lui
dire c'est possible je crois en toi
prends les chances certains et avance
quand on regarde les témoignages de
jeunes issus d' migration qui ont réussi
et et vraiment excellemment réussi ils
expliquent qu'ils avaient eu des parents
peut-être iltrés analphabète mais qui
croyaient en eux curieux qui leuront
fait prendre présent en tout cas présent
et exigeant non leur donnz confiance en
eux leur disant c'est possible nous on
est venu ici pour que toi tu es un
avenir et les enfants il regardez cette
chef d'orchestre une des rares chef
d'orchestre femme qui s'appelle Z vous
la connaissezès bien bon ben elle ses
parents étaient de milieu pas du tout
aisé ils étaient juste méloman ils l'ont
emmené voilà ils étaient àtin ils l'ont
emmené écouter des concerts magnifiques
à Paris et maintenant elle est chef
d'orchestre mondialement connu elle elle
a euh
etilles il c'est des exceptions oui mais
tous il disent la même chose que cont
àdation vous voulez compter sur le doigt
de la
main parle c'est pas à la mode d'être
bien mais en même temps il y a
énormément de gens bien dont on ne parle
jamais qui sont issu de ça pas un très
joli livre qui parle justement de ces
femmes ici de de l'immigration qui on
réuss don don cette chef d'orchestre
mais il y a aussi rachidti mais il y a
aussi la
Naj qu'il faudrait pas oublier c'est
c'est une distinction qu'on ne fait plus
et là c'est c'est vraiment dommage c'est
que l'instruction c'est pas l'éducation
et que l'école
siécole se contentait de l'instruction
et de l'instruction des matières de base
de ces matières de base découlent déjà
une certaine éducation mais que ce soit
toutes les matières bien enseignant
amène à au respect à la à la
connaissance à la tolérance à la
diversité il y a pas besoin d'éduquer
l'éducation c'est chez les
parents soit là que l'école instruise
mais ça c'est pas le problème de
l'éducation non mais si il faut bien on
peut pas laisser sur le bord de la route
là c'est l'œuf et la poule je veux dire
que l'école apprenne que l'école
instruise et qu'après on essaie de on
règle le problème des des des pauvres
enfants qui NT pas de parents des
parents absents mais je ve dire c'est
pas à l'école de faire l'éducation de
des jeunes Français d'ailleurs ça marche
pas c'est possible euh ouais euh je sais
pas quoi enfin non c'est pour moi le le
système scolaire n'a pas vocation à à à
éduquer
euh moi je pense que le on a ce qu'on on
apprend on apprend la vie la vie en
dehors de l'école surtout à l'intérieur
de l'école on on essaie de domter un peu
les corps
euh les esprits les mettre dans un moule
standardiser un peu tout ça moi je
trouve que c'est plus intéressant de
d'apprendre d'apprendre la vie à
l'extérieur
Mustapha parce que c'est presque au
président du Football Club de trappe que
je m'adresse parce que vous vous avez
des enfants vous avez des gamin comme ça
dont et vous participez leur éducation
d'une façon générale non alors moi je
suis beaucoup plus tranché encore sur
cette question moi j'ai le sentiment que
la France et la laïcité en France n'est
à l'épreuve sauf par certains qui
veulent la mettre à l'épreuve la très
grande majorité l'ont bien compris l'a
bien comprise et je pense qu'on peut
revenir sur des fondamentaux donc moi
là-dessus je considère que si
chacun fait son objet c'est-à-dire
l'école a un objet et qu'elle y reste
effectivement c'est celle de
l'enseignement c'est la transmission du
savoir mais c'est consubstantiel à
l'éducation parce que quand on transmet
un savoir qui est celui bah finalement
d'apprendre bah on apprend dans la vie
d'arriver à l'heure le proviseur quand
arrive pas
géeation pour dansplin mon objet le FO
j'ai pas envie d'en sortir j'ai pas
envie de rentrer dans des débats au sein
du club de foot je comprends pas tous
les débats qu'on a autour de l'éducation
nationale pour moi fait jouer au foot ça
les
édu c'est un vrai
complément av je suis pas persuadé que
tous les corps constituer fasse bien
l'objet et là je parle des politiques
par exemple les politiques qui ont une
responsabilité je dis pas toutes mais
qui sont pas forcément non plus dans
leur objet quel est l'objet lorsque vous
avez des des maires dans une
commune qui normalement devrait incarner
une politique mais une politique c'est
tjours facile c'est simple par exemple
quelle est la politique sportive d'une
ville moi je la connais pas or ça fait
12 ans que je veux incarner une
politique sportive au club de foot et la
politique sportive c'est quoi c'est très
simple c'est du foot pour tous au
moindre coût par contre avec l'idée que
on ait chercher des performances une
fois qu'on a dit ça c'est l'éducation
qui m'intéresse par le football parce
que le football est consubstantiel de
cette éducation là et au quel cas c'est
l'éducation qui m'intéresse quand vous
avez une commune qui pense que le club
de foot doit briller par son étoile doit
briller par son vitrine doit briller par
ses seigor la bah la politique sportive
du club et celle de la ville n'est plus
la même et au sommet on n plus d'accord
et à la base on a des tas de gens sur le
sur sur le sur le carreau ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il faut qu'on revienne à
des choses très simples très basiques à
l'objet moi c'est le foot j'en sors pas
on me demande d'ouvrir les débat oui
c'est é un c'est é un fabuleux et j'ai
des exemples comme ça est-ce que c'est
pas plutôt par des choses comme parce
qu'on fait beaucoup repter de
responsabilité sur sur l'éducation
nationale qui n peu met déjà qui qui est
en crise qui a du mal à à instruire les
les enfants euh qui a du mal à à faire
qu' qui sache écrit en sortant de
l'école primaire il y a un taux d'échec
scolaire qui est absolument considérable
est-ce qu'en plus lui faire porter des
responsabilités supplémentaires c'est
pour ça qu'il faut arrêter de de
proposer ces ces moments de débat qui
n'en finissent plus dans les écoles à
chaque fois qu'il y a un problème dans
la société le grand mot des des des
hommes politiques de droite comme de
gauche ah oui il faudrait qu'on débatte
dans les écoles il y a pas il y a pas à
débattre dans les écoles je veux dire
dans les écoles on apprend et puis c'est
tout et quand on apprend et ben quand on
est plus grand après on débat mais on n
pas à débattre à faire des moi moi je
j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y ait
d'opposition par rapport à ce que j'ai
dit qui sont les bases de la
constitution d'une personnalité hein
toujours pareil génétique éducation
environnement quand vous parlez de
l'environnement c'est l'environnement
familial l'environnement au lycée
ouement c'est très
vaste quand même mais l'environnement
c'est très vaste bien sûr que il y a
l'environnement familial dans lequel on
habite le quartier dans lequel on habite
le pays dans lequel on habite je disais
qu'il y avait une relation réelle entre
entre la constitution de la personnalité
humaine et celle des sociétés la société
française n'est pas autre chose que la
résultante de sa génétique son histoire
de l'éducation complète de la société au
sens le plus large de son environnement
nous sommes dans un pays au climat
tempéré
avec grand écart entre le latin et
l'anglo-saxon ça c'est notre génétique
nos rencontres c'est qui ce sont les
grands hommes qui ont fait notre
histoire le dernier dat F le général de
Gaulle ce fut une des grandes rencontres
du peuple français et de la société
française donc voyez que il y a bien une
relation entre l'humain individu et sa
société celle dans laquelle il vit et je
n'entends pas de choses qui me
contredisent dans ce domain mais je
reparlais alors plus de manière plus TER
à terre de l'éducation qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit faire qu'est-ce
qu' doit faire à l'école c'est pas
seulement dies pas se dire tout à
l'heure ce que disait cette femme chef
d'orchestre qui queil faut laisser une
place plus grande à la culture et que
plus la culture place moins la religion
a place déjà et que c'était et que après
elle elle poussait les enfants à
évidemment pratiquer des instruments de
musique il y a la musique il faut une
exigence une régularité très bien mais
il a aussi l'histoire c'est très bien la
musique mais je dire on voit pas non
plus a plein de matièr mais ne négligons
pas des matières de base la géographie
l'histoire
extrond vous m' posé la question il y a
un élément qui manque de plus en plus un
élément qui manque de plus en plus dans
l'éducation enfin moi c'est ce que je
ressens sur les terrains il y a de moins
en moins d'adultes c'est aussi simple
que ça il y a de moins en moins de moins
en moins d'adultes tout simplement et
probablement qu'on peut poser la
question de savoir si dans les familles
les adultes sont présents dans leur
famille au sein même du foyer familial
dans l'école et dans le club de foot et
tout mon travail consiste et vous étiez
présent samedi au vœux c'est d'arriver à
une proportion de 8020 c'est-à-dire 80 %
de licenciés et 20 % d'adultes et je
disais souvent qu'on a pas besoin de
discourir beaucoup les enfants attendre
souvent des attitudes attendre
simplement que que l'on soit et pas
forcément qu'on débatte et moi ce que je
demande aux adultes c'est d'être présent
pas forcément de discourir et de laisser
faire le travail de nos éducateurs qui
portent le nom d'éducation comme les
écoles et très sincèrement Patrice je
pourrais vous donner un petit exemple
mais peut-être que ça peut être non
alors l'exemple l'exemple il est suivant
lorsque l'on fait un tournoi de foot à
la fin des tournois on on fait des
remises de coupe normalement le premier
qui reçoit la coupe c'est le dernier de
la compétition et ben figurez-vous que
les adultes qui conduisent les voitures
emmènent les enfants et considèrent
qu'ils ont pas de temps à perdre parce
que la coupe ne leur revient pas celle
du premier voilà un exemple très simple
et je peux vous en je peux vous en
donner des dizaines c'est symbolique
c'est simple mais l'adulte ne veut plus
participer nivisme pour moi ça en est et
on parle beaucoup des enfants on fait
allez je vais oser pratiquement ce qu'on
en veut c'est-à-dire on peut arriver à
faire passer des messages à nos enfants
la preuve c'est qu'il y a des mecs qui
sont virtuels aujourd'hui ils sont loin
et ils font passer des messages ils sont
virtuels ils sont loin je pass je pense
à ceux qui se radicalisent nous sommes
proches et on a des choses à dire on n
arriverait pas je pense qu'à moment
donné chacun d'entre nous en tous les
cas les adultes pourraent au moins se
poser cette question est-ce que je suis
suffisamment proche des gosses Florence
il en a un avec qui on va pas discuter
c'est l'enfant de 8 ans qui a été mis en
garde à vue pour incitation à la au
terrorisme euh c'est un peu
jeune c'est carrément interdit quo enfin
bon j'ai trouvé alors il était
manifestement avec son père au
commissariat voilà il y a peut-être j'ai
pas tout à fait suivi ce dossier là mais
franchement avir un gamin de 8 ans dans
un commissariat de police c'est c'est
totalement non productif a rien à
faire non mais le problème c'est pas le
gamin le problème sont les parents
justement tout à fait d'abord c'est
l'inrtion civique de façon un peu
cynique mais d'abord il n pas été garde
à vue ça a duré Mo une demi-heure il a
été convoqué avec son père alors ce
gamin euh propageait des des idées
contre lequel nous sommes tous oui il
les a pas inventé lui-même il les a pas
inventé il les a donc écouté chez lui
donc c'est tout à fait normal que que le
le que l'État français enfin que que que
les pouvoirs publics s'inquiètent et et
convoquent les deux c'est d'autant plus
normal que il y a quelques temps quand
Christine tobira a été injurié dans les
manifestations par des enfants du même
âge qu'il a traité de guenon là tout le
monde trouve qu'on s'intéresse au au
gamins et c'était tout à fait juste donc
c'est pas une question d'âge si s'il y a
des enfants qui
profè répète ce qu'on entendil justement
donc on et on convoque les parents mais
on convoque on peut convoquer on peut
convoquer le père au commissariat de
police mais pas enfin moi le gamin je
trouve ça c'est pas le lieu et le lieu
c'est que ce gamin là faut lui parler
faut lui
expliquer c'est juste que peut-être que
c'est même pas le débat parce que
probablement qu' a un emballement
médiatique sur cette question même pas
l'histoire on n pas convoqué le gamin
pour ses propos il semblerait qu'il y a
des problèmes de violence dans la
famille qu'on ait convoqué les parents
donc le père et le fils probablement sur
cette histoire là le reste étant celle
que la peut-être que les médias ont
envie de de faire passer parce que des
histoires comme C j'en ai plein j' plein
c'est pas les médias c'est un un c'est
un confrère de notre ami qui est un
opposant destosi et qui passe son temps
à à Moné tout en
puiss y a probablement un jeu derrière
tout ça il y a une autre solution dont
on parle beaucoup c'est le service civil
ou le service militaire Antonin est-ce
que vous seriez prêt à faire un service
6 mois oui de de votre temps pour un
service civil ou militaire d'ailleurs
euh ouais alors je ferai une très grande
différence entre les deux pour moi les
deux institutions ne représente pas du
tout la même chose d'un côté on a le
service civil qui pousse à s'engager
pour la société pour le bien commun de
l'autre côté on a une institution
paternaliste viriliste qui encourage à
faire la guerre donc moi c'est tout vu
je je pense que effectivement ça peut
être intéressant de continuer à
promouvoir le service civil l'engagement
citoyen néanmoins l'institution
militaire pour moi euh bon on a déjà des
professionnels il me semble que c'est
que ça ça ser plutôt bien comme ça quoi
ça sera en tout cas probablement une des
grandes annonces de de François Hollande
dans sa conférence de de jeudi
j'aimerais rebondir sur l'objet ce que
disait mustafha c'est quel est l'objet
de de cette réforme l'objet c'est de
dire que il faut essayer de ramasser les
G qui sont qui sont les décrocheurs et
voir plus par il y a quand même dans les
moins de 25 ans en France il y a 1
million de jeunes qui sont ni dans
l'éducation ni en emploi qui n'ont plus
rien quoi qui n'ont plus rien et donc je
pense que face à ça on est en train de
dire bon il faut qu'on essae de
récupérer ces ces gamins ces jeunes pour
leur les remettre dans le circuit et je
trouve que c'est quand même révélateur
d'une société qui est plus capable parce
que c'est aussi par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé au début du mois de janvier
le 7 janvier le
les gens on dit mais finalement la
suppression du service militaire parirac
à l'époque est peut-être pas été une
bonne ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
la société n'est plus capable de faire
en S que les gens en sorte que les gens
vivent ensemble et je trouve ça vraiment
très très grave de se dire va falloir
qu'on fasse un truc obligatoire ah oui
non mais faut qu'on fasse un truc
obligatoire pour qu'on puisse arriver à
les refaire des mal enfin je trouve que
c'est un peu
fou service militaire et qui
récupér ça sauf qu'on dit
pas tout à fait la même chose tous parce
que moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on voudrait
probablement nous emmener plutôt à un
service
militaire qui soit obligatoire parce que
la vraie question de fond c'est de dire
nos armées ne suffirai plus si on était
en notre sein attaqué dans nos rues et
que chacun puisse prendre la défense de
son drapeau c'est probablement ça la
question qui est posée c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas réarmer je
pense qu'on seentre plus vers un service
civil que militaire et
ben j'ai jamais entendu
ça n par contre il y a une chose qu'il
faut simplement noter c'est que le
service militaire que j'ai fait comme
plein de gens de mon âge permettait des
rencontres et quand je parlais tout à
l'heure
pardon la possibité de faire des
rencontres les rencontres cétait mais
non mais les rencontres c'était des mecs
qui venaient de milieu tellement
différents obligé de s'abiller de la
même façon de dormir dans des dortoirs à
12 15 20 et qui se croisait il qui pu
des pied et l'autre qui était tout
propre et puis ces gens-là se croisaient
et ils restaient ensemble des mois
durant et ils apprenaient effectivement
à vivre ensemble aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on constate on constate que notamment
les réseaux sociaux ou bien la façon
même d'organiser pour les jeunes je
parle sous le contrôle d'Antonin fait
que ils sont beaucoup enfermés dans des
bulles et ils n'en sortent pas et il y a
pas de communication entre les bulles le
service que j'espère être CIVI et non
pas militaire obligatoire pour
l'ensemble des jeunes jeunes filles et
jeunes garçons permettrait de
décloisonner tous ces réseaux et de
faire que les gens puissent se
rencontrer dans des conditions où ils ne
maîtriseront pas qui ils vont rencontrer
parce qu'il faut qu'il y est un
phénomène de hasard il faut qu'on puisse
rencontrer des gens riches des gens
pauvres des gens grands des intelligents
des moins intelligents mais il faut
qu'on vive ensemble c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend donc la Ress la seule chose
disent les spécialistes je permet de de
préciser ça c'est que si vous faites un
service civil il ne pourra jamais être
obligatoire parce que ce sont des
associations qu'elle n'ura pas les
moyens
mais non il non pas les moyens c'est une
question mais non vousvez pas de der
vous n'avez pas de derteur dans le dans
le service
civil n'est pas obligatoire
jeéigato j'ai une solution par exemple
par exemple la
JD JAPD par exemple on peut pas passer
le bac si on a pas son son passe JPD et
ben voilà je veux dire il y a plein
d'institutions dans la vie qui
sont sont quiment qui sont quasiment
obligatoires donc voilà là il y a des
systèmes c'est pour intégrer c'est pas
pour rejeter quand même c'est 16 ans
qu'on do faire moi je suis un peu étonné
qu'on puisse encore dire que le service
militaire quel qu'il soit soit un truc
pour encourager à faire la guerre ça me
paraît mais complètement démodé comme
vision du monde enfin
jeoncer c'est ridicule encourager la
guerre enfin je veux dire prouve une
méconnaissance de ce former des gens à
tuer d'autres gens c'est c'est pas faire
la Guer à se défendre à se
défendrec tout quo vous dites d'une
méconnaissance totale de la moitié de de
ce qui se passe dans le monde et que
vous soyz antimilitariste c'est une
chose mais le service militaire n'a
jamais encouragé à faire la guerre au
pire ça a appris à faire la guerre c'est
encouragé à faire la guerre c'est une
aberration de dire un TR apprendre
apprendre à faire la guerre c'est desjà
encouragés à faire pas du tout pas du
tout mais
non on se croirait dans les années
60 y a 4000 personnes par an qui font
leur service civil avec 120000 demandes
150000 demandes voilà et qui ont pas les
moyens on a dû éter le même monsieur don
je me souvens monter un monstre après
après non parce qu'après concernant les
moyens c'est bon ok rétablir un service
militaire obligatoire ça coûte 3
milliards par an ok on dit on a pas les
3 milliards quand on calcule ce que
apportait dans les dans les cités dans
les dans les petites communes et partout
le service
militaire constrits qui étaient là ça
faisait ça faisait franchement tourner
la machine donc arrêtons avec cette
histoire d'argent eu cumulé mais les
casines dans les banlieux mais bien sûr
bien évidemment évid
idée pardon mais on est là aussi pour un
peu de temps en temps dramatiser moi je
pense qu'en plus il en va du service et
de la Défense nationale comme de l'impôt
si tout le monde payait l'impôt les gens
seraient plus
raisonnables au moment de réclamer des
dépenses et si tout le monde savait ce
que c'était visiblement tout le monde ne
sait pas que une armée et que la défense
nationale les gens feraient aussi
attention à ne pas être des vates en
guerre quand on sait à peu près ce que
c'est qu'un fusil en sachant rien en
voulant tout oublier c'est très facile
de d'être dans des positions ass
curieuse allez on l'a tous été à son âge
quasiment dire qu'on éta an si je peux
permre je trouve ça très
irrespectue vraiment c'est pas une
question
d' bien ça vous regarde moi
je je considère
que un bon moyen de d'intégrer les gens
c'est discuter c'est d'apprendre le
débat c'est pas de s'engager
collectivement s'organiser
collectivement c'est pas d'apprendre un
fusil ou il s'agit pas parce que parce
par parle d'intégtion organis des
débats va répondre service civil ça
peutre pardon j'ai pas été irresectueux
j'ai simplement dit que je l'avais été
moi-même et que ça arrive aussi de
changer d'avis dans la vie ça aussi
c'est une méthode de pouvoir écouter
tout ce qui se dit par ailleurs et
probablement même de changer d'Ave et
j'ai changé d'avis sur la question mais
c'est pas mais c'est pas ce que je
voulais dire c'était pas irresectueux
non plus mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que l'armée n'a même pas besoin de de
entre guillemets du peuple quand on a
une armée qu'on veut faire la guerre
avec la bombe nucléaire les bombes
nucléaires ça peut être très rapide donc
si on veut vraiment la faire la guerre
si l'armée est faite pour la guerre on a
des boutons sur lesquels on peut appuyer
pour envahir le et dévaster le peuple
mais la question n'est même pas là c'est
de dire que faut pas être naïf non plus
et les événements nous ont nous ont
quand même montré que la naïveté et
parce que je considère qu'on est une
sacrée naïveté la question
c'était tout à l'heure sur la laïcité
est-elle menacée la France la laïcité
pour moi ne l'est pas la France non plus
même si elle est combatue même si de
temps en temps il y a des événements qui
sont douloureux je parlais d'un autre
pays la dernière fois qui a été ravagé
par le fait qu'on puisse être attaqué et
ça s'appelle se défendre voilà donc
c'est de ça dont on parle maintenant la
vraie question c'est de savoir si on en
a les moyens de savoir ce qu'on peut y
mettre dedans si c'est obligatoire ou
pas mais les vraies questions on
probablement plus JEI après la
conférence de presse de de François
Hollande je voudrais qu'on termine par
un autre sujet ce qui est peut-être le
le on en parle beaucoup du retour de
l'antisémitisme et d'un certain d'une
certaine forme d'antisémitisme peut-être
d'un nouvel antisémitisme je vous
propose de voir d'abord un sujet sur la
protection des sites
juifs des militaires du 152e régiment
d'infanterie de Colmar en faction devant
la synagogue de Versailles c'était ce
samedi matin et depuis ce weekend ce
sont en tout 11 sites principaux de la
communauté juive dans le département qui
font l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière de la part de l'armée
crèche éclees et lieu de culte le préfet
a d'ailleurs rencontré Samuel Sand le
président de la communauté versaillaise
pour expliquer le dispositif et rassurer
sur chacun des sites il y a une équipe
de 12 militaires qui se relais pour
assurer une permanence
H24 et pour protéger la communauté et
rassurer la communauté notre objectif
c'est de dire à la communauté qu'on est
bien sûr avec elle dans ces moments
difficiles et douloureux et qu'on lui
donne les moyens de sa sécurité vous
savez que les les attentats ont ciblé
fortement la communauté juive au moment
notamment de
des des très graves des très graves
actions de de
l'hypercacher à Paris donc la communauté
juive se
sent vraiment meurtrie les 11 lieux
faisant l'objet d'une surveillance
particulière se situe notamment à
versaill mais aussi comme ici à MPa
d'autres villes sont concernées poigné
la forêt et un peu plus loin poiss
Sartrouville ou encore Saint-Germain au
lait ce mardi le préfet des ivelines
rassemblera tous les chefs d'équipe afin
de faire le point sur le dispositif et
présenter une feuille de route il sera
aussi question de l'organisation des
rapports entre militair police nationale
et police municipal le plan Vigipirate
alerte attentat mobilise 10000
militaires en France 6000 rien que sur
l'île- de- France et 132 dans les
ivelines cette voilà montée de
l'antisémitisme on voit en effet de plus
en plus de de de de de Juifs qui disent
comme les employés du du supermarché
cacher qui a été attaqué euh par
Koulibali on va revenir en Israël il y
avait d'ailleurs netanou qui les a
incité à le faire encouragé à le faire
est-ce que vous sentez est-ce que il y a
pas un nouvel antisémitisme qu'on a
caché pendant longtemps profit d'un
antisémitisme un vieil antisémitisme
français qu'on a pas voulu voir ça a
l'air d'être un autre celui-là non c'est
un nouvel
antisitisme qui est beaucoup plus
virulent frontal que l'antisémitisme
français euh qui est une exportation
génoui du conflit Isra palestiniens en
France non oui c'est notamment dans les
Blieux souscouvert d'antisionisme une
certaine partie de de de du du pouvoir
et de la classe politique c'est abrité
derrière cet antisionisme pour mettre
une sorte de de chapeau sur
l'antisémitisme non mais n n nos jeunes
dans les banlieux non c'est pas
l'antisémitisme l'antisionisme et cetera
mais non c'est c'est l'antisionisme est
souvent juste une espèce de de de
paravant pour un antisémitisme réel et
virulent et extrêmement dangereux et on
l'a vu là donc donc je pense qu'il est
pas pire maintenant simplement
maintenant bah il a hélas éclaté au
grand jour avec les conséquence horrible
qu'on a vu il y a plus d'agression il
plus des enfants qui se font
tabasser parents qui disent on part en
Israël en parce que ça fait des années
qu'on dit mais non mais c'est pas grave
regardez on en revient à ce qu'on disait
après laffiremera je veux dire tout le
monde s'est rendormi au bout de 3 jours
au bout de 3 jours plus personne n'
parlait on a tendance à oublier notre
histoire moi qui ont je suis passionné
d'histoire je je constate que le
problème sur le peuple juif est inscrit
depuis que le peuple juif existe donc
l'antisémitisme n'est pas nouveaupère
que mais vous n'avez pas oublié
l'affaire drefus vous avez pas oublié ce
qui s'est passé dans les médias bah
évidemment c'est la même chose
évidemment ououi ça ressemble beaucoup
alors maintenant il y a des moyens
médiatiques énormes et et et la grande
différence c'est l'existence du Pay
Israël qui je vous le rappelle a quand
même été créé après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qui a fait que on a réussi à
fixer pour ce peuple un pays bon c'est
ce qui a changé fondamentalement dans la
donne de l'antijuif depuis la nuit des
temps donc aujourd'hui l'expression de
la violence traduite dans les journaux
est absolument abominable et ce qui se
passe est
insupportable mais ce phénomène n'est
pas nouveau voilà alors il va falloir
l'éradiquer à un moment donné relié par
les M
son même que moi je suis tout à fait de
la vie de Patrice ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas du tout ce ne sont pas les
mêmes gens qui sont antisémite
maintenant et et avant la guerre de de
avant 39 40 c'est pas du tout les mêmes
gens ce n'est pas ce sont pas du tout
les mêmes ressorts c'est c'est ça n'a
strictement rien à voir c'était pas le
cas en
45 p c'est les deux parce que enfin
quand par exemple on on écoute les
discours de d'un certain parti rougebrun
comme on dit euh en fait il présente des
des
livres égalité
réconciliationd égalité réconciliation
par exemple qui présente des livres
d'avant la guerre 39 45 et qui en même
temps tient des discours hyper virulents
contre contre Israël il y a vraiment un
mélange en fait
de souscouvert de d'antisionisme en fait
il y a a le vieux le vie ter des goû y a
le vieux fond antisémite qui qui
Ress
profitfa la première chose que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'autant tout à
l'heure je parlais de rester
fondamentalement vissé sur les objets
qu'on avait tous à à construire et à
bâtir de la meilleure manière de la même
façon il y a un truc que je supporte pas
c'est qu'on touche au symboles et là ce
sont des symboles qu'on attaque on parle
de synagogue on par peut parler des
mosquées on peut parler on peut parler
on peut parler des des églises des
profanations de tombe et dès que ça
touche à un symbole je suis juste
effondré ça c'est la première chose la
seconde chose c'est que Jea juste faire
référence à ma propre histoire parce que
on a aussi une histoire de temps en
temps c'est ce qui fait àquel on fait
référence mais par exemple les les Juifs
dans dans le Maghreb avaient une
coexistence absolument Pacifique en
France dans les banlieu de la même façon
et moi j'ai grandi autant je pourrais
parler du voile euh aujourd'hui versus
une époque autant la relation pareil
entre les juifs ou les musulmans et les
catholiques que j'ai bien évidemment cé
de la même façon ça c'est effectivement
totalement tendu depuis cette
coexistence à laquelle moi j'ai
participé à laquelle que j'ai vécu je la
retrouve plus aujourd'hui et
effectivement il y a des il y a des
choses qui ont changer il y a des choses
qui ont bougé et et le point de fixation
dont parle tout à l'heure probablement
que maintenant est-ce que on peut
peut-être même plus avoir le débat
c'estàd qu'il y a des gens qui sont
antiionistes réellement antiionistes et
pas antisémite
simplement pour le cou pouir
condam c'est là tu as raison c'est sous
couvertantisisme ils le disent mais il y
a quand même des gens qui sont aussi
antisist qui sont
juifs
conusion non mais c'est juste c'est
juste terrorisant quoi c'est accablant
c'est ut est-ce qu'il faut qu'il reste
en France évidemment qu'il faut qu'il
reste en France évidemment qu'il faut
qu'il reste en France mais il faut que
on fasse tout pour essayer d'apaiser
cette situation et de faire ensemble on
est toujours sur la même problématique
les gens ne se parlent plus les gens ne
se croisent plus les gens se il y a des
oui non alors certain il y a soit ceux
qui réagissent plus soit ceux qui
essayent de réagir un peu au travers
d'association d'essayer de faire des
choses pour que résoudre le problème et
puis après il y a ceux qui se ha et et
cette espèce de de haine qu'il y a de
violence est vraiment très inquiétante
et je comprends uneexloitation de la
guerre tout simplement faç faut qu'il
reste oui faut qu'il reste c'est surtout
après les Juifs ça sera qui c'est qu'
moment doné ce raisonnement qui pourrait
consister même des gens dont tu parles
tout à l'heure ces gens-là probablement
qui seront eux-mêmes leurs propres
victimes ils seront eux-mêmes les
prochaines victimes on s'attaque aux
Juifs demain on s'attaquera à qui voilà
de la même façon donc cette exclusion
qu'on peut avoir c'est juste que on
touche pas au symbole et on touche pas
ça on démontre qu'on est pas dans on
démontre qu'on est pas dans de la
laïcité hein parce que la laïitéou on
est loin de laïité là il y st un du
service public de la télévision sur la
commémoration de la Libération d'
peut-être que peut-être que ça aurait
été bien que des des gens regardent ça
il y a eu plein de témoignages dans les
écoles de qui ont frappé les élèves
absolument merci merci à tous on se
retrouve très prochainement pour un
prochain PAF si vous êtes d'accord ok à
très
vite